here we go yeah so I just wanted to take
a few minutes to talk about the what
appears to be the current state of the
DCE you the films that Warner Brothers
making based off of DC properties
because there's a lot going on a lot
that kind of isn't going on so I think
sort of the biggest thing right now is
there are roots it's this completely
reports as to exactly how extensive this
all is but the last few times these
sorts of things have come up they've
turned out to be more or less true and
that is reshoots for Justice League
rumor is right now that they are
extensive now reshoots ended up
themselves aren't news reshoots happen
on every big-budget film and it kind of
always annoys me when internet-based
media treats like a big stories I all of
there's research why are there recent
because they're scheduled at the time
they didn't think of there's always
reshoots because you get in the editing
room you're going oh you know what we
could we need another go on that or you
know we really should have had a scene
here to transition better or oh you know
what we should we need to drop that
scene but that means we need to drop
this information elsewhere so that
everything flows that's best filmmaking
reshoots are a part of that but like I
said the last couple times this the news
of extensive reshoots have come out they
turned out to be pretty accurate and
those are kind of the two extremes if
you want to use examples of how good or
bad this could turn out one is Suicide
Squad the other is rogue one now Row one
I liked quite a bit and as far as I can
tell the reshoots did help shape it into
what it is but I'm going to come back to
that so starting with Suicide Squad and
I know some people like this movie I'm
friends with some people who like this
movie a lot but even if you like it I
think you have to cop to the fact that
it's a choppy movie and you can tell
just from the feel of it that this thing
was rearranged and rejiggered and put
together from disparate parts and you
just you just feel that with the way
it's structured the way that it treats
certain information like it's a big
reveal but it's not that the film has
already shown us and
or go or how jarring the transition in
terms of tone is from how the thing
opens to how it is in the bulk of the
action you know the whole thing does
have a flow is very very choppy now if
you're going on the more positive side
of the results of massive research we
have Road one which as I said I like
quite a bit but even rogue one the the
front end of it again it's choppy you
can see the stitches that are holding it
together and we've got stuff that just
feels either shoehorned in because it
was added later or feels completely
vestigial because they probably should
have just dropped it because it was a
holdover for the earlier version I'm
talking about stuff like sagar era and
mind squid what my point is that massive
reshoots in and of themselves don't
necessarily mean the end result is going
to be bad although they're not a great
indication they are a sense that
something is not currently working
however it does show you that there's a
desire to fix it not just cobble
something together and shove out into
theaters which is what studios will do
when they get into an editing room and
realize they've got a turkey but decide
it's not worth the money to fix it
obviously this is a major film it's
worth the money to fix whatever the
problem is that being said there was
also word right when the thing started
shooting that they had a writer on set
to you know be doing rewrites
immediately because they were trying I
think they were trying to respond to the
criticisms that were leveled against
Batman V Superman as they were shooting
they had to do it that way because they
didn't put a gap in between when Batman
V Superman came out and when they
started filming Justice League the
shooting picked up almost immediately
and I think that has really bitten them
in the butt because if they had
sometimes I think they really just
assumed that well they'd either roll the
dice or they assumed that everyone was
going to love Batman V Superman and that
was what all fans wanted again I know
some people really liked it but it was
divisive and don't just give me all this
Marvel 10 but no there are lots of DC
fans who really have a lot of problems
with that movie so it was divisive
amongst the fans and they didn't
Wow the kind of gas to make adjustments
from that reaction before they got into
filming the Justice League so they've
been trying to do it as they go and
obviously that didn't work and now
they're trying to fix it after the fact
again that could work but that this has
been everything kind of indicates a
troubled production and not troubled in
the sense of like onset drama but in
terms of trying to come up with a
coherent and a result and I'm not
shocked by this because it's the same
creative team that did Batman V Superman
why would we expect Justice League to be
significantly different and of course
now we're entering a world where the
studio at least wants it to be no relief
notably different but you've got the
same guys behind it who initially
conceived it when they thought Batman V
Superman was going to be what everyone
wanted so it was conceived initially in
that vein and they're trying to change
it into something else as they go that's
that's not a good indication now as far
as other stuff going on we've had some
directors named Sherman out in regards
to flight absolutely Cobb right now I
don't think the flash movie is actually
going to happen if it does it's
absolutely not happening inside with
this 2018 release date they need to just
they need to stop kidding themselves I
know he's supposed to be the fastest man
alive
they're not going to shoot it that quick
all they've got
solidly is a star then it's not entirely
clear if the page one rewrite script
that they ordered is ready to go they're
talking two directors and even if
they've got a new script that is ready
to go the directors that they're talking
to people like Robert Zemeckis these are
people who are going to want to put
their own stamp on it they're not going
to just want to be handed a script and
shoot it as is so it's going to have to
be refitted there's no time none of this
is going to happen and I honestly do
expect that it'll get pushed back to an
indeterminant day and eventually
canceled because I have said this before
I can't think of anything that you would
do in a flash movie that has not already
been done on the flash TV show
speaking of films that aren't going to
happen cyborg is not going to happen
well now I'll put a slide out search on
that if cyborg turns out to be the
surprise breakout star of the Justice
League movie and let that happen he's
not getting his own movie that's
absolutely
not going to happen and I think Warner
Brothers knows this because all of the
newer projects that you know have
they've been announcing pushing forward
and actually successfully attaching
talent to in terms of directors have all
been related to and it really does seem
like Warner Brothers would much rather
be making the Batman extended universe
rather than the DC extended universe and
that's a part of it it's kind of just to
say look just go ahead and do that
because Batman really does seem to be
the only character you guys have ever
had any luck in figuring out they've
stumbled with Batman - don't get me
wrong but at least they've got a
stronger track record with Batman than
they have had with Q per man or any of
these other characters that they're
introducing so far so yep fine just make
it and just make it the Batman extended
universe lean this other stuff alone I'm
not quite going there yet because early
word on Wonder Woman has been coming out
now not official reviews those are all
still embargoed but people who went to
press screenings who went to preview
screenings have now they've hit the
point where they have been allowed to go
on social media and give their
impressions of the film and they are
very positive now you always got to pick
these things with a grain of salt
because this is generalizing so that's
not me saying general audiences don't
know anything but that is me saying if
you go to a preview screening with you
know a crowd people who are excited to
be there you're not necessarily going to
be looking at the thing is critically
and I say that from experience I
actually really like the film alien
versus Predator
and I acknowledge that a big part of the
reason why I like it is because I saw it
at a preview screening with a ton of
people who were thrilled to be there and
we had a great time watching this movie
and if I hadn't watched it under those
circumstances and I gone you know after
it came out and it was a less crowded
theater and it wasn't packed can be worn
tearing I probably would have gone yeah
like a lot of people did so I understand
that that environment can really eat amp
up the reaction either positive or
negative
whatever the reaction people tend to
have at those screenings it gets bumped
up to 11 but it has pretty much all been
positive and for a point
comparison gap guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 which is very good and I like a
heck of a lot that also had very
positive initial reaction from these
sorts of screenings but there were a lot
more sort of McAfee I feel like thinks
good but you know there's this thing and
maybe signs as good as the first and
maybe that just because they had
something to compare it to but this has
been more overwhelmingly positive and
that is a good first word on Wonder
Woman now at this point I'm not
reversing my stance on my previous
anthem that I'm not going to the Wonder
Woman movie and as a reminder the reason
for my stance on that is unless I have
reason to believe that it is great I
don't want to give my money to Warner
Brothers anymore I don't want to
financially encourage them to keep doing
what they're doing is I think what
they're doing is terrible and
disrespectful to these characters but I
have always maintained that if were
Wonder Woman is that it's genuinely
great not just ok but genuinely great I
will give it a shot and I am going I'm
now paying enough attention that I'm
open to it and I would like it to be I
would like to be able to sit down in
front of you guys and say you know what
I was convinced he couldn't possibly be
good I was wrong I don't know if that'll
happen I would very much like it to but
we'll see when we get there
here's the thing though I wish I could
hang a whole bunch of hope on that way
well one woman will be great and then
everything's fine from here we'll know
it's not because after Wonder Woman is
Justice League which oh boy guys I'm not
it's not going to be impossible for that
to be good but the chances of that one
coming out and being a winner - ah
that's got a lot stacked against it and
more the point even if Wonder Woman is
great the way the film has been set up
in terms of the story that they're
telling and where it is they've shot
themselves in the foot as far as
following it up goes because I think if
it's going to be great a part of what is
going to allow us to be graded that it
is divorced enough from the Cinematic
Universe they've been creating because
it is set so far ahead in time that it
didn't have to you know feed and feed
and feed into and feel like those other
films it was allowed to be its own thing
but unfortunately because of the
timeline and what they've already
established about the character they
can't really do that again because they
established in Batman V Superman but
after World War one
she went away and she only just came
back in Batman V Superman so what can
you deal with her
you basically have no choice but to
bring her off to modern era which means
well now we're back into the territory
of the world as shaped by Batman V
Superman until they can reset the whole
thing if they're even able to do that
even in terms of Wonder Woman as an
individual franchise even if this movie
is great that does not make me suddenly
go well at least we've got this one
franchise like we'll have the one film I
figure maybe the only thing that they
could do is that they went as a
follow-up you know and it's set timeline
in between they'd have to go like all in
on the Greek mythology angle and she'd
have to be kept out of the real world
and I guess it depends on what works and
doesn't work about the movie as to
whether or not that's a good idea I
guess that's where things are again I
want Wonder Woman to be good I want
Wonder Woman to be great but even if it
is it's gonna it's going to exist as an
outlier for what we've gotten so far and
what I think we're going to get in the
immediate future the more separate from
everything going on that a film is
allowed to be as opposed to trying to
set up and be integrated with everything
else the better shot is going to have at
being any good so that gives me a little
hope for maybe Aquaman that's kind of I
met and and Wonder Woman hopefully
fingers crossed not committing to seeing
it yet I want to see what the initial
actual reviews say but um I'm hopeful
and I haven't been able to say that for
a while again though not hopeful for the
DC EU just hopeful for Wonder Woman
that's not nothing so that's where I am
on the state of all this stuff what are
your thoughts on of whatever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council geeks give a listen to the
council geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher there's also the
punch like a girl podcast also available
on iTunes and stitcher and until next
and this council is adjourned
[Applause]